he is in the baseball hall of fame
two-time cy young award winner who is
going to be part of the american century
celebrity golf championship taking place
as always in beautiful
south lake tahoe nevada at the edgewood
tahoe on july
7th through the 11th and you'll see it
on nbc and more tom glavin
here on the rich how are you doing tom
i'm doing great rich how you doing i am
doing better for talking to you how's
your golf game you ready for this what's
going on
uh you know it's i'll tell you this i'm
hitting the ball really good at the
moment
scoring has been an issue so i got a few
more days to work on
okay now let's be on let's go i'm just
going to go straight butter here
you smoltz and maddox the best player
is who is it uh small t for sure okay
i understand his game's not good real
good right now according to him so
he was he was on last week and he
you know i just i i i i'm a guy who
can't concentrate playing golf at all
if i break 90 it really is cause to
celebrate so hearing somebody who
probably gives shots back to the course
complain about his game because he can't
make this
the you know the champions tour uh it's
it's literally the smallest violin
playing for me i'll be honest with you
tom
i can't argue with you i mean you know i
mean for all the things that we could be
complaining about in life he's
complaining because yeah he can't make a
senior tour
in a sport that he's not a professional
at so yeah my goodness i really feel bad
for him well tom unfortunately i think
uh the
g-h-i-n or the gain is public what do
you got over there chris what are you
going to do yeah i'm i'm seeing
like tom's checking in at a 2.8 is that
right tom
2.8 seems right yeah so it's crept up a
tiny bit wow yeah that's about right so
what's maddox then
where's where's greg uh i would say greg
and i are probably the same he and i are
you know right around the three or four
handicapped and smoky's uh
you know scratched to a probably plus
one or plus two
so what was it like back in the day when
avery's starting and the three of you
could go out and play golf while avery
had
had the bump that night what do you got
for me i mean it was great the
poor guy who had the pitch that night um
i mean you just hope
you just hope you weren't playing pine
valley or something like that
just to say see you later so were you
were you playing golf regularly when
when you were
playing with those two guys and just
because i was hearing that that you guys
would just go and
you'd go out there and you'd you'd play
some rounds of golf when you were not
pitching
did that happen frequently we played all
the time i mean if we weren't pitching
we were playing
um other than maybe a weekend series
somewhere you know because weekends are
always a little bit harder to get onto
golf courses so
right um you know that was a little bit
of a challenge but smolty was
the absolute best at getting tee times
and setting stuff up so you know it was
yeah if we had a seven-day road trip and
you know that included
obviously a saturday and sunday we
probably played at least four days
because we had to pitch one day
so so smoltz was the the golf concierge
tom he was he was yes he was fantastic
give me your best story what's your best
story who you played with who who who
rounded out a foursome one time where
smokes was able to get you
we've played with so many good guys over
the years i think you know i mean
look one of our best golf trips was you
know we landed
at laguardia on a sunday night and
walked out the back of the plane smokey
had a car waiting for us on the tarmac
we drove out to long island played
uh new york national in the morning on
monday yep
had lunch played shinnecock in the
afternoon and then was back
back in the city that night so that was
a pretty good day but i mean we played
with so many guys and down there in
orlando when we moved over to orlando
for spring training i mean
you know tiger was there we played with
him a bunch marco mayor of paul azinger
i mean all those guys were down there
and
lee jams and we played with so many of
those guys it was a blast oh
man and plus it doesn't matter if you
you know when you're playing the mets
because chipper pretty much had them in
his bag anyway right didn't matter
yeah yeah yeah all we had to do was show
up make sure make sure chipper was good
and everything's good
oh man um what was the angriest you've
ever seen bobby cox
tom um
i mean you know there were a couple we
had uh
i remember one time um
you know one of the big things with
bobby was particularly as it came to
the bullpen was you know don't ask him
what your role is you know and just
essentially it was you know your role is
to pitch when i tell you to pitch so
we had gotten a guy over uh it was 1990
late 90 somewhere in there when bobby
took over again
on the bench and we had a long trip back
from san francisco back to atlanta
and one of our relievers i won't mention
his name but he was complaining about
you know how he was being
used and whatever and you know back in
those days you might have a beer or two
on the charter
on the way home so we convinced them
that when we got back to atlanta now
mind you that was like probably
5 30 6 o'clock in the morning after an
all-night flight we convinced it would
be a good idea to go and talk to bobby
about his role
when we got back to atlanta so needless
to say
we were kind of all hovering around the
outdoor the outside of bobby's office
door
uh as this guy went in and sure enough
it was a
an expletive um
conversation about essentially your role
is when i pick up the phone and call
down there and tell you to get up it's
your turn to pitch that's your role now
get the hell out of here
oh see but but you're you're you're
listening through the keyhole
pretty much right trying to see that
back then we were
still in atlanta fulton county stadium
real old stadiums right
bobby's bobby's office kind of was at
the end of a row of lockers so there was
a little bit of a corner that you could
hide behind that
obscured bobby's door to you so bobby
couldn't see you and we couldn't see him
but we could hear everything so
tom glavin here on the rich eisen show
what do you think of uh
the the checking of pitchers these days
tom for the spider tack and all the
sticky stuff what do you think about
what's going on
you know look at i i come down a little
bit on both sides i i
understand uh the pitcher's uh
frustration a little bit that this is
being done in the middle of the season
um that part i get but at the same time
um
you know i've said i i don't think they
have anybody to blame but themselves
um you know i think everybody knew this
was going
on in the game to some extent and and
kind of
turned the cheek to it so to speak um
and and kind of
i don't want to say hit but kind of you
know
left it under the guys that you know if
this helps guys
have a little bit better command and we
don't have guys getting hit
in the head in the batter's box then
it's somewhat of a safety issue okay
we'll turn the cheek but i think clearly
um it got taken too far and
i i i don't think major league baseball
had much of a choice really to step in
and do something about it and
so i think from that standpoint um it's
it's the player's fault because they did
take it too far
um you know they had somewhat of a a
gentleman's agreement so to speak that
went too far and and
you know i think baseball had to get it
under control now what are they going to
do moving forward
i don't know um you know i've heard
conversations about well maybe we need
to allow them to use sunscreen or maybe
we
so if there's a way to differentiate
that you know between spider tack and
sunscreen
in terms of having a little bit of a
grip versus
you know really enhancing a guy's spin
rate on a fastball or a curveball then
then i think that's going to be a
discussion i
i personally just don't know how they go
about doing that yeah we heard we had
don mattingly on the show yesterday tom
and um he's saying that that players
his guys would come back from the
batter's box and just say that ball
moved in a way that i've never seen in
my entire life
and don would say that he would you hear
guys say that right
and especially when they talk about spin
rate um you know and i know it's
for for all guys like me who played the
game right a lot of this
analytical stuff is just putting numbers
to what your eyes see
and you know i don't i don't need a spin
rate
uh meter so to speak to tell me if a guy
has or threw a good curveball you can
see it
but certainly having spin rate i think
helps the average fan
understand the difference between a good
curveball and a mediocre curveball now
as it relates to a fastball i guess
that's where spin rate
um became more of an understanding for
me when it came to the fastball because
you do hear guys talk about
hitters seeing a fastball going to hit a
fastball where they think it's going to
end up based on gravity and all these
things and
because of the spin rate it doesn't do
that it stays it stays on plane and
that's why
guys are swinging and missing so much on
high fastball so
i think there's something to that how
much of it i don't know um
but i do you know i see all that but
you know it you do you see some pitches
nowadays that you kind of are just like
wow that was
that was you know and i think you see
some bad ones too right i mean we've
i've seen more
in the games i've done this year rich
i've seen more 55 foot curveballs than
i've seen in a long long
time um and i'm assuming that has
something to do with
you know the sticky stuff that guys have
on their hands yeah i i would think so
for sure um and so i guess last thing
for you
is is back in your day um
what was there always a concern about
having a grip
on the baseball as much as we're hearing
about right now
tom there's always yes there's always
been a concern about the grip
um i think that the conversation now
is it's a little bit different right
like i know for for me
um and i'll i'll speak for me if i was
going to go
and when i pitched in new york or when i
was in atlanta and you went to new york
or you went to chicago in april it's
cold
and when you're when it's cold and your
hands are cold it's hard to hold onto
that baseball
so yeah you're always searching for
something in in that
scenario to try and have a better grip
on the ball
not only to to command it but to make it
be able to make it spin and do the
things you wanted it to do whether it
was making it spin on a curveball
or for me to make it spin the way i
wanted it to spin on my sinker and my
changeup
knowing i was going to get the movement
i'm looking for and the location
ultimately that i'm looking
for we didn't define it back then in
terms of of spin rate
right we didn't we didn't think of it
that way um i think that's more a part
of the conversation in today's game
but yeah there's always that that that
fight so to speak that balance of
man it's cold out i can't really feel my
fingers
this ball feels like a snowball in my
hand i'm not really sure where it's
going
um so you know yeah you would try to
find any way you could
um to keep a little bit of perspiration
on your hands so you could grip that
baseball
tom glavin here on the rich eyes and
show he's going to be playing in the
american century celebrity golf
championship
in tahoe in a couple weeks just a few
more minutes left with the baseball hall
of famer
here on the rich eisen show do you think
we'll ever see somebody win 300 games
again somebody's coming in the league
right now win 300 games
i hate to say never um i'm not a big no
you know i'm a
i'm a never say never kind of guy um but
if you're asking me to bet on it i would
say no
um and it's not because not because
there aren't guys
in the game talented enough to do it i
mean if you're going on pure talent
alone then jake the ground is going to
win 300 games
right the problem is
the problem for the most part is you got
to pitch
20 years to win 300 games and
i just don't see anybody in today's game
doing that like i don't see
guys being able to stay healthy long
enough
to pitch for 20 years you know when you
look at so many of the guys in today's
game
you know there are a lot of guys that
are max effort guys and there are some
guys that aren't but even a guy like
jake degrom who i don't consider
to be a max effort guy i love his
delivery i think everything's kind of
smooth and easy and
it comes out 100 miles an hour you
you're seeing this year
and i hope it doesn't amount to anything
but you're seeing this year he's he's
had a little bit of
issues here and there he's had some
dings and some dents a little bit this
year
so to think that he's going to be able
to pitch at this level
for 15 more years throwing as hard as he
does
that's the part for me that i just don't
see anybody staying healthy long enough
to do it and then you
on the flip side of that you know you
start talking about guys who are max
effort guys
there's no way your body's holding up
for 20 years so i think that's the big
thing
it's not talent there are guys that have
plenty of talent to do it
i just don't think their bodies are
going to hold up for 20 years before i
let you go tom
uh i've worked with him i've gotten to
know him i love him he's one of my
favorite people i've gotten to meet give
me your favorite dione sanders story
you got one for me tom when are you
running
took i'll just say this about dion when
when we traded for dion
i i was probably amongst the guys that
were like what are we doing right
um i couldn't have been more wrong about
the deon was a great teammate
uh he would give you the shirt off his
back but dion was the first
um and and really one of the best at
understanding how to market deon
and how to market prime time i mean dion
in the clubhouse with the guys was just
a funny guy a fun-loving guy
and when that red light went on and it
was in front of him it was it was prime
time
and he he was really other than maybe
muhammad ali
he was the first guy that i saw that
really knew how to do that
and you know like i said i think he
maybe took a little bit of a bad rap at
times but
uh look he was a great teammate he was
fun to be around
um you know doing everything that he did
playing football playing baseball the
whole i still think he would have been a
hell of a baseball player if he spent
more time doing it but
he was pretty darn good at football well
tom you know obviously
uh you you had a front row seat for this
you know
had had uh you know you guys won the
world series the one which he was
playing with you he he could have been
mvp of that world series tom
no he wouldn't have i would have
my bad tom my bad he would have been in
the running
let me let me rephrase that he would
have been in the running he would have
been in the running for
fair enough mvp
i love it there is no statute of
limitation on pride
there is none that's right 100
that is hilarious all right so do you do
you know who you're paired with
uh in tahoe yet or did you find out when
you arrived do you know that yet now we
find out when we get there generally
they'll have me
small z and maddox on day one and then
uh you know multi will be amongst the
leaders and he'll go to another group
and greg and i will be
towards the back somewhere this year but
i'm hoping to change that towards the
back i mean you're not going to be
paired with barkley
tom let's go oh no no not that far back
maybe the middle of the bus not the back
of the bus
take care of yourself tom glavin i
really appreciate the time let's do this
more often i i miss talking to you
i barely just scratched the surface on
the stories that you could tell
appreciate it i'd love to do it you know
where to find me now so anytime i
appreciate that that's tom glavin
hall of famer man in cooperstown
two-time cy young award winner right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here